- [Elvis] Come on in,
don't mind the dog.
- I'm thrilled with the dog.
Hey gang.
How are ya?
- Wisdom of the day,
I'm thrilled with the dog.
Hope you're writing all these down.
- I am, do I have to put these on?
- No.
- Yes, no great,
- [Elvis] No. Only if you
take a phone call.
- [Gary] I'll take it okay,
well I like phone calls.
So wait a minute wait a minute,
real quick just to set the tone,
you have a gold mic and
everybody else doesn't?
- [Group] Yes.
- [Woman 1] Welcome to the dynamic.
- [Danielle] It's Elvis Duran
and the Morning Show.
- Got it.
- I'm the pompous ass.
- It's a pleasure,
I'm excited to be here.
- Gary, first of all,
Charlamagne is a
very dear friend of ours.
When he found out you
were gonna be on the show
he was like you are
gonna love GaryVee.
- [Gary] He is great, we
had a lot of fun together
and he's a really sharp dude.
- [Woman] Yeah, he's wonderful.
- He is, and he's off on his own
and doing so well with
so many different things
and he gives you a lot of credit.
- That's super nice.
But I think his
hustle and his ambition
has a lot to do with that
but I'll take any credit
I don't deserve
any day of the week.
- Let me just start
up the lawnmower
real quick here, you tell
me if I'm right or wrong
then I wanna move
onto some other things.
- Go ahead.
- Gary, born and raised in--
- Born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union.
- [Elvis] And raised in New Jersey.
- Raised in New Jersey,
first came over to Queens
lived there for two
years then mainly grew up
in Edison, New Jersey.
- [Elvis] Your parents
or your father
had a wine store.
- Yes my dad came
here with 100 bucks,
lived the American dream,
eventually became a stock boy,
manager, and then eventually
bought a store in Clark, New Jersey
called Shoppers Discount Liquors,
and then opened a store in
Springfield, New Jersey,
I was a entrepreneur
lemonade stand,
baseball card shows
and Phillipsburg Mall
Bridgewater Mall,
it's fun to do this show
obviously a lot of locals.
And then eventually my dad
dragged me into the store.
And I revolutionized the
wine industry by launching
one of the first e-commerce
wine businesses
called WineLibrary.com,
and built up one of the biggest
wine shops in America
over in Milburn,
Springfield, Short Hills, New Jersey.
- Even those who don't
know a lot about wine
which is most of us,
you can watch
Gary in the old days
when he was doing these videos
he was doing these--
- WineLibraryTV.
- WineLibTV shows,
it was like a normal average guy
trying wine, without going
oh it's got the undertones
and overtones of you know socks.
You would drink wine and go
yeah this is good.
And we'd buy it.
- That was a big thing,
so YouTube came out,
so I was right
about e-commerce,
I was right about
Google AdWords,
email marketing,
and then YouTube
comes out and I'm like
this is gonna be big,
and so four months
after YouTube started
in 2006 I started WineLibraryTV,
and everybody who's
listening right now
just think to yourself
do you know somebody
that's into wine?
And I think most
people are gonna say yes.
And what everybody knows,
is that the second
somebody just gets
a little bit of wine knowledge,
they become a straight jerk.
Right, right, they're like oh
you're drinking the wrong year
right or you didn't
smell that properly.
And I was a Jersey kid
that came from not a
whole lot but I knew
an obnoxious
amount about wine
'cause I grew up in the business.
- Right.
- So when
I started WineLibraryTV,
I just referred to
wines the way I grew up.
Like this smells like a
Hulk Hogan wrestling figure
or this is like a racquetball--
- Right.
- or this is like for example
a lot of Cabernets smell
like Big League Chew.
(laughing)
You love Big League Chew?
I do too.
- You make wine
fun and approachable
and now wine, because of
you, a lot of people give you
credit wine has become
a major major business
for all of us to enjoy in America.
- I think that's overstated but--
- Take all the credit here.
- No, I'll take a little
bit of Cha's credit
but what I will say is this,
I know question
created wine drinkers
in the 20 year old demo,
21 and older demo at a time where
most people were talking
down to people about wine
I was talking with
people about wine.
- Now I don't want this
to become all about wine
this is just how GaryVee
got into where he is
and he took an idea, which
you can apply with almost
anything in life and turn
it into something huge.
Going back to the days
when you were a kid selling
trading baseball cards
and selling them,
he would go to these
trade card shows,
whatever you call them.
- Yep.
- Where he had lots of
competition, lot of people
had much better
cards to sell and trade
and make money from, but he
just found a different way
to do it which made
him become the leader
as a kid in this little bitty
industry you knew nothing
about but look what you did.
So what did we walk
away from that learning
and how can we all apply it?
- For a lot of people that
are listening right now
I think you know it's
funny the way you just
positioned that, the truth is
I was a D and F student,
right, so Martin Luther King
School in Edison, New Jersey,
North Hunterton High School
in Hunterton County, those teachers
they didn't see this coming
and so, what I realized was
this was what
I was good at, right?
I was good at looking at
things a little bit different
than everybody else.
I was good at telling stories,
I was good at selling.
I was good at really
working much harder
than anybody else in the
things that I was most
interested in, and so
what I was able to do
in the time in the '80s and
'90s when it wasn't as cool
right now being an
entrepreneur is cool. Right?
It's cool, everybody
wants to be a CEO
an entrepreneur, when
I was getting D's and F's
I was making $3,000 a
weekend as a 14 year old.
But my teachers and
my friends' parents
didn't think I was a winner
because the scoring back
then was about school.
- Yeah.
- And so the one thing
I would take away from this
as everybody's listening
and driving right now is
look, you can decide to
choose what the market
says is cool now,
or you can try to
figure yourself out
and disproportionately triple
down on what you're good at.
- Well the good example
here is who do you know
other than Gary who was
a C, D, or F student
but because they just didn't
thrive in a preset
the tests were already
written for you society
but when they came out of that
and could make their own rules,
come up with their
own tests for themselves
they could thrive and
fly like an eagle.
And that's the thing, when
you live by other people's
rules you're not gonna give
yourself a chance to succeed.
- Take a step back right
now and think about
who we all admire in the world.
Right, they're all
people that punted
the system, they're people
that practiced singing
since they were five.
They're people that
shot 10,000 basketballs
every morning.
It's always that.
99% of the people right now
that are listening to this
are playing in the middle.
They're playing in a game
that was structured for them,
they're risk adverse they fear,
and most importantly they
fear what other people think.
That was I think the
best thing that ever
happened to me, much like
you with your gold mic,
I didn't care what
other people said.
And it's not because
I didn't respect it.
I get feedback all the time that
might be negative, this and that
I respect it, I listen to it,
but at the end of the day
I'm just not built to have it dictate
my one at-bat at life.
- Okay, how do we apply it then?
- [Woman] Yeah have
you always been like that
or is that just something
that you had to learn?
- I think a little bit of both.
Look, I got very lucky, I think
not coming from much
is a huge advantage.
You know, I'm writing a
book in my head right now
that I'll eventually write called
I Wish Everybody
Was An Immigrant.
When you come from nothing,
when you come from zero,
when you have to
walk two miles to K Mart
in Dover, New Jersey,
you know, that's an advantage.
Right, so--
- See, not many people would think
that's an advantage.
- Yeah, until they look around
and they look around and realize
all these immigrants own
all these businesses.
Right, like when you
realize how great
America really is.
You know right now
we're living through
such an interesting time right,
and everybody wants to
tell you how bad it is.
And there's so much, there's
always things that are tough.
Like, I'm very lucky I was
born in a different place
I travel a bunch,
nobody's moving to Canada
or Mexico so quick.
Right, nobody's moving
somewhere else,
this is a special place
and you can either
choose to look at
the small percentage
of bad things
or you can
choose to look at
the far majority of
amazing things that happen
in this country, and
that's what I choose to do
and I think once people
realize all the opportunity
and realize,
first and foremost, Elvis,
nobody's gonna care
about your complaining.
I love when people complain.
Who's gonna care?
And so how do you apply it?
It's a mindset, right,
have I always had it?
Look, I had the benefit
of having a mother
who's the greatest in the world,
that instilled so much
self-esteem in me
that peer pressure, and
negativity never even got close
to the center of my soul, right?
I got lucky that way.
- But you found yourself.
- I found myself, I think it's funny
and I remember it, it
was like fourth grade
I got an F on a science test
and for some unknown reason
I mean remember you're
really young in fourth grade,
for some weird reason I was like,
"I just don't care about Saturn
"and I have a funny feeling
it's not gonna matter to me."
- Wow there you go.
What about Uranus?
- Yeah I care about Uranus.
(laughing)
- By the way--
- That was set up so perfectly.
- Okay I'm almost caffeinated
up to GaryVee's level,
GaryVee is here,
Gary Vaynerchuk of course
the CEO of the world.
(laughing)
But we're about to get
into the meat and potatoes--
- Okay.
- of how this can
work for everyone.
- I love it.
- First of all,
I am sick and effing tired
of people calling millennials lazy
and not caring and not
wanting to contribute.
And I'm tired of it
because I don't believe it,
I think everyone has
an equal opportunity
to be lazy or dynamic.
- You're preaching, I mean
I get this all the time
because I have such
a big fan base of
40, 50, 60 year old
executives and they're like
how do you deal
with these millennials?
I'm like look--
- Stop calling them
millennials for one.
- There's no millennials.
There's Rick, there's Susan,
there's Sarah, right I know
unlimited 40 to 50 year olds
that are lazy and have no drive.
And I have tons of 23
year olds that work at
VaynerMedia that if I give
them one dollar more an hour,
they'll work 72 hours
in a 24 hour day.
- Talk about it then.
I'm 22 years old,
I'm paying off my debt
from college.
- We should get into that
racket to begin with but--
- So if I'm 22 years old,
I've got the whole
world ahead of me.
I've got more opportunity
than most people
so why am I branded a loser?
- Oh because old
people want to complain
about the next generation.
We become bitter.
- So don't listen to 'em.
- Of course not.
- So let's say I'm 22, tell
me what I need to be doing
right now to make my--
- Every 22 to 30 year old
that's listening to this
right now you have one
major flaw I'm generalizing,
you have lack of patience.
Elvis, if you really
wanna talk about it,
what people are making is
they've got college debts,
they've got their ambitions,
one of the two let's
say it's a positive
let's say it's a
negative, and they pop out
at 22, 23, and they take
jobs that pay them
$4,000 more for something
they don't wanna do
because they lack patience.
- Wow.
- Uh-huh.
That's the punchline, my friend.
- Do what you want to do.
- How old are you?
- 52 almost.
- Are you blown away as
I am as a 40 year old man
how young you feel?
- Oh yeah.
- If I told 25 year old Elvis
at 52 you would feel like this--
- I feel better, no,
no these are the days,
Winston Churchill
my favorite quote,
these are the days.
- And that's the punchline.
If I could wish
anything right now
I would wish that
everybody who's listening
that's under 30 could feel
what you and I feel right now.
I mean I don't even
feel like I've started.
- [Woman] Hmmm.
- You know,
and so when you're 22
I remember being 22
wasn't that that that long ago,
40's old.
I would've been like woof,
in that 18 years if I'm
gonna buy the New York Jets
like I want to I better have
done it there,
now I realize my god,
life is so long.
And the way we're taking
care of ourselves.
You know, your parents,
my parents
at our ages,
they were not as healthy.
We're gonna live much longer.
We're gonna live
into our 90s, 100s like
we have so much time.
- I'm gonna go beyond that.
- Okay respect,
so the punchline in
one way or the other
I would ask everybody
who's listening right now
to take one step
back and say okay
either I'm working too hard
and I'm stressing these loans
or what I have to achieve
to prove to my dad
that I'm good, right,
and I'm not going to
Coachella or this or that or
you're doing too much of that stuff
and you can
work a little harder,
but you've got so
much more time
and so I think the one
thing and it was funny
it was that awkward pause
that we all just took,
patience is not something
we do not talk about.
- [Woman] Well and it's
something that it doesn't
seem to be valued right
now, because if you notice
like I remember, this was
years ago, but back when
Oprah was on and
had her show everyday,
she did so many
episodes about young kids
who were geniuses,
or young kids who were 10
and already graduated college.
And so in our society
we're being told that
the faster you do something,
the better you are.
- It's why listening to
society's a bad idea.
If you listen to society
the world's on fire
and we're all gonna die.
If you listen to society
everybody's gonna build
Facebook and Snapchat.
- Then who do we listen to?
Ourself?
- Yourself.
- Listen to yourself.
- Now the problem is,
a lot of us don't like
what ourselves are
telling to ourselves.
- The inner voice can
be our worst enemy.
- Uh-huh, that's right,
so first and foremost, what
I think everybody should do
and even I'm saying this
actually I'm giving myself advice
right now I'm just getting
meta and stepping away
from this interview,
you need to do things that
make you a little uncomfortable.
Way too many people
have made decisions
without ever trying, right?
So that's one thing that I think--
- [Woman] So like it's
too scary I don't wanna do it.
- That's right, and you
have to taste things.
Like I love when people
are like, "Oh I hate sushi."
I'm like, "Have you had it?"
They're like, "No."
- [Danielle] That's me.
(laughing)
I don't wanna taste it.
- And so to me that's the
most fascinating thing
of how humans are, right?
That's what we do, and
so the punchline is this
look here's what I'll
say on this little genre
as we're jamming on it,
You have one life.
One of the great things
that happened to me
growing up was there was
a lot of grandparents
that visited, I had a lot
of kids in my neighborhood,
and for some unknown
reason I don't know if I'm
an old soul or what it is,
I used to on the playground
go and sit with old people.
- Yeah.
- And just talk to them.
And let me tell you one
thing about old people,
80, 90, the one thing
that has stuck with me
as a child and sits with me today
is they regret.
Regret scares the
crap out of me, Elvis.
- Do you have any
regret right now?
- No, but I also am
40 so I feel like
I can get a lot of things done.
I feel like a lot of things
are still in front of me
but when you get to 80 and 90
and you can't do everything
and you know that
you don't have as much time
the one thing I see in
so many of their eyes
is "I wish I."
Everything's "I wish I."
- They give us these lists,
they give us the gift
of these lists all the time.
Like you'll have
a healthcare worker
who works with people who are
on their deathbed,
they'll ask them
give us the top five things
you regret from life.
They tell us what they regret--
- Did you see that article
with the Hospice worker
you saw that, yeah.
- It really is fascinating,
we're gonna get
into that in a moment.
- Okay.
- But, GaryVee is here,
we're just getting started,
we're just revving
these engines up.
(chuckling)
I want to talk to you about
the dream everyone has of
not working for the man
and doing it for themselves,
and how they can use
where they are now to
catapult them into where
they wanna go.
- I've got thoughts.
- A few seconds ago,
GaryVee's here
we'll be back with him
with more right after this.
Gary Vaynerchuk is here,
GaryVee we call him.
Make sure you're following him
everywhere you can
because every day
he gives us some thoughts
that really really
catapult us into the day.
And books, yeah, he's got
books, he's got everything.
You don't wanna be known
as a motivational speaker
you're more of a--
- Listen I've built a
$50 million business
and a $100 million
business that I think
a lot of people when they
hear motivational speakers
and things of that nature--
- It creeps us out.
- It creeps me out.
I mean somebody who's,
I love practicality.
Look I'm very motivating.
I understand that.
You know, mom and dad had
sex at the right moment
and gave me that DNA, I get that,
but I like that I didn't
start telling the world
you can do it until I did it,
instead of what we see
on Instagram which is
22-year-old life coaches
trying to tell us
what to do.
- It's kind of weird,
usually when guests are here
they have a laundry list of
things they wanna promote.
- [Danielle] Yeah.
- We were asking Gary
earlier what he wanted
to promote today, it was like
well I'm not here
to promote anything.
Well, okay.
- Yeah I'm like let's get the callers.
- Let's talk to callers.
- [Danielle] You're just
helping people.
- Okay, so we're gonna talk
to Ann Marie in one second
but earlier you
gave us great advice,
we need to be more patient
in order to tackle life and win.
What do you mean by patient?
We need to be patient with what?
- Life, everybody wants this car,
everybody wants to
achieve, everybody wants
these things, first of all
we should want less things.
And by the way
you wanna stereotype
in the other direction everybody?
I think millennials are
the greatest generation
of not wanting big TVs
and watches and fast cars.
They wanna go
and experience things,
they wanna live a little
bit of a better lifestyle.
It comes down to this Elvis,
I think you have to work hard.
Like, just so everybody knows,
we haven't gotten
into this subject yet,
working hard is the cost
of entry to anything.
You know zero people
that are successful
that don't work their face off.
You know zero people.
Now, they may have money,
'cause mommy and daddy made
money and gave it to them.
But people that actually
built their own success,
you know zero people
that have had success
that did not put in
obnoxious amounts of work.
- Very good, we're
about to talk to someone
about that in just a second.
- Okay.
- But dad always said,
I'm thinking of these great
piece of advice from my
father who's passed away,
you can't have it all
where would you put it?
(laughing)
- He's right.
- Where you gonna put it?
- By the way, real quick and
I know we're going to the
call but I wanna say this,
something back to Cha,
we talked about him,
when I was on his show,
I talked about
selling stuff in
your house on Ebay.
I've gotten 50 to 100
emails in the last
30 to 60 days of people
auditing their home,
selling everything they
didn't want on Ebay
and people literally
making $1,000, $3,000,
$10,000 to take a vacation
on literally just stuff
like an owl lamp.
- Hey hey hey hey.
- Oh sorry, sorry, sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry.
- Back away from the owl lamp.
- Sorry sorry sorry sorry.
- Who do you think you are?
- Sorry sorry, sorry,
everything was going so well
until I referenced the
damn owl, I'm sorry.
- We'll get rid of everyone
here before the owl lamp.
- Got it, got it.
- All right, let's get Anna Marie
oh my god I can't believe
you're making fun of my
owl lamp, Anne Marie say
good morning to GaryVee
what's on your
mind today, Anne Marie?
- [Woman] Morning.
- Good morning.
Okay.
- [Anne Marie] But that's
continuous but once you--
- What kind of
store do you have?
- [Anne Marie] I own a
chocolate pretzel company--
- Love it.
- [Anne Marie] Pleasure
of meeting Danielle.
- [Danielle] Oh my gosh
her pretzels are amazing.
- Well look, you just
took the first step
you're getting
advertisement on one of the
biggest shows in America.
- [Danielle] So good.
- [Anne Marie] I didn't think--
- Anne Marie, I think first of all
you really saved yourself
'cause I was gonna razz you
but you did a great job
I don't think your pretzel
shop will ever spend
enough time and
money on Facebook ads.
And so I wanna give
you really good advice
'cause I want you
to email me in a year
and say Gary you did it,
spend an obnoxious amount
of time on Facebook ads.
Run a lot of ads within
a one mile radius
of your actual store,
I'm sure you're doing
online business, are you
running Facebook ads?
Are you spending
money on Facebook ads?
- [Anne Marie] We're not
yet, everything you know
I've been very fortunate
because it has strictly
been worked out,
I actually don't do any
advertising or marketing
only on social media.
- Spend money on Facebook ads,
'cause here's my punchline,
as fortunate and as
amazing as you've been
you can be bigger and better.
And so I would deploy
a certain percentage
of your profits to Facebook ads,
they will work.
And also--
- They're actually very
economical, Facebook ads.
- Facebook advertising, for
everybody who's listening
right now, Facebook advertising
is the number one
deal in marketing period
in the world, not in social media,
not in digital, in the whole game.
- And you gotta celebrate
something Anne Marie
before we let you go,
the day you signed your
divorce papers and you
opened your business
and signed that lease, the most
important day of your life.
- I love that.
- Anne Marie--
- Thanks Anne Marie.
- [Danielle] Send us pretzels.
I love that she stuck it to him,
good for her.
- Hey, before we take another call.
- Yeah.
- My takeaway today that
just makes my nipples so hard
about what GaryVee said earlier
yes look I could cut
glass with them look.
- [Woman] They are very hard.
- Holy.
- Yeah, for whatever reason,
the happy people on Earth
are the most silent.
- Yes.
- Therefore, we only hear
from the loud, unhappy people.
And it's doing something
that's awful to us
in our lives.
Talk about that.
And how do we fix it?
- We fix it by going on one
of the biggest radio shows
in the country and
challenging everybody
who's listening right now
that if you're in a good mood
that's something smart
to Tweet about too.
Like why have we defaulted
only to producing conversation
around negativity, because
let me tell everybody who's
listening right now what happens,
people start believing that's
what's actually happening.
And so every day, every day,
99% of this audience
has good moments
but they never think about
sharing that on Facebook,
yet the second somebody
cuts them off on the road
of the cashier is slow,
or they don't like
something that's happening
in politics they get nasty.
It's rubbernecking, and we
have to start talking positive
because this is our lives
and we're going down
a slippery slope and
so I think positivity
needs a momentum booster.
- Let me ask you this
Gary, in your opinion,
are there more
people who are happy
or more people who are
miserable in life right now?
- You know what the best part
is, I'm not even gonna use
my opinion, the data shows
that more people are happy.
Do you know how
amazing the world is?
Crime is down.
You know, the media wants
to tell you it's not, right?
So many things are in
great places right now,
now somebody's listening
and saying easy for you,
that's fine,
but you have to understand
you live in a country
that allows you the chance
to get out of that.
Like, the market doesn't care
if you're poor, you're black,
you're white, you're a girl.
If those pretzels are delicious
they don't care
if an alien made it.
And that's what's
great about the market,
the market doesn't care
one way or another,
which means you have a shot.
Your parents may be judging you,
your wife may say you're a loser.
Your neighborhood
might say you suck.
But the market that gets
you out of your situation,
it's actually not judging you.
And that is why this is the
greatest time to be alive.
- Is that why our
show does fairly well?
If I can just toot our
own horn for a second.
We are probably one of
the only places to go
where we are amplifying
happy and positive thinking
than everywhere else.
- Have you ever heard of Oprah?
- [Danielle] Yeah.
- She did okay.
- Who's that?
- [Danielle] But even on
days when crap is going on
in the world which
is so often now,
we'll come in and say look
we know a lot of
crap is going on,
we need to give
you some positivity.
- Let me give you when
crap was really going on.
When our grandparents were alive.
This isn't crap.
This is not crap guys,
we have it so good.
Like everyone thinks it's so bad,
Americans lived in fear
that Russia was gonna
bomb us every day
from 1950 to 1980.
This is not crap.
- They're not about to bomb us?
- Well actually
Putin's a character.
(laughter)
- It's true, it's true.
You know and this is
why it's so important
to study history, people
wonder why history
is such an important
thing to study,
it is because you need
to see where we've been
and how we got to where we are.
Let's go talk to Steven. Steven,
say hi to GaryVee. What's up?
- Hey Steven.
How old are you?
- [Steven] I'm 28.
- See this is a perfect,
you know, this question
would've never been asked
10 years ago, because
of start up culture
and I'm not blaming you,
this is for everybody who's
listening, everybody thinks
you need start up capital.
Right, like where's
my angel investor?
I don't know any rich friends.
Steven, I'll be very
honest with you,
if you're so ambitious,
why don't you go out
and sell stuff on the side
get a second or third
job, sell stuff on eBay,
you can easily figure out a way
to muster up an extra five,
10, 15, 20, 30,000 dollars
by hustling extra.
I think if you
don't have connections,
that's your only
alternative right?
Like if you do have
connections great,
but to really answer
your question
I think a lot of people
wanna start this app,
and they have this big idea,
but what they don't
realize is they should
go and do something
completely different
to muster up the dollars,
or back to patience,
get two jobs, eat crow,
stop watching Game of Thrones,
don't play Pokemon Go,
go all in for three years
and do nothing,
listen, Steven, I did not have,
I did not have my 20s at all.
All my friends now
show up on Facebook
and they're like
Gary, you're so lucky,
you're so lucky and
I reply to all of them.
I'm like I'm lucky?
Let me remind you something,
remember 1999
to 2009 when you went
to the Jersey Shore
every weekend and
hooked up with chicks?
I worked.
So my answer to Steven
and everybody else is
if you're so ambitious, show me.
- [Steven] It's difficult.
- No it's not, Steven and I'm
not trying to bust with you
here's my real question,
if you really want it
and by the way, you get to
choose your work life balance,
but you know that's on you
that's not me to choose
or anybody else, what I'm
passionate about Steven
to be very frank with you
is what did you do from
Friday 5 PM until Monday 7 AM,
I'm just curious and
I don't think you shouldn't
have a weekend but
I think everybody's ambition
actually is more
predicated on their actions
than their words.
My friends tell me all the
time they're so ambitious,
and I'm like if that's true
then you punt leisure,
and you punt concerts
at Jones Beach
and you work.
- Wow.
Steven, best of luck to you,
thank you for listening to us.
- Thanks, brother.
- Yeah sometimes these
pills are hard to swallow.
- And listen, I think Steven's a great guy
and I used Steven as a
catalyst for a lot of people
that are listening, I don't
know Steven's situation.
- You dashed his
hopes and dreams.
- No, Elvis I think a
lot of people say that
I never say, I don't wanna
say that I'm ambitious,
I wanna show you
that I'm ambitious.
Go watch my
Snapchat, GaryVEE,
and go watch my Snapchat
and see that I'm up at
5:37 in the morning
and see that I'm in
meetings at 11:58 PM.
There's no question to Garrett
if I'm ambitious, I'm showing you.
And so I just think we live in,
by the way, I think
it's so good in America
that most people are soft.
People like this--
- Talk about it.
- Easy, people like to
say they're ambitious,
but look what they do,
they look at the negative.
Hey, I don't have connections
like some other guy
or girl I heard of
that got $50,000 from
people to start their
start up, woe is me.
Woe is me?
There's never been a generation,
our parents, our grandparents,
they never heard
of start up capital.
They worked two jobs, saved
money for seven years,
then took the money they saved
and risked it
and built a business.
- GoFundMe was not around.
- There was no, I'm
gonna start a Kickstarter
and everything's gonna
be okay, it's crazy.
- You don't like GoFundMe?
- No I love it, I just also know
the data shows that
99% of the people
don't get their money.
Again, it's like I think
a screwdriver works,
but if you don't
know how to use it,
got it? GoFundMe's
a great tool
but do you have
such a great idea
that America is gonna be excited
to write you a check
so that you can do it?
- So,
I wish we had another five hours.
- [Group] Yeah.
- I can come back.
- When can you come back?
- Tomorrow's good.
(laughing)
Is this over?
- Yeah, almost.
- I'm very upset.
- I hate that, I know I hate that.
- [Danielle] He's so upset.
- But no no no, do me a favor.
- I feel like we're just getting
the East Coast hustlers going.
- I know.
- I feel like people are
like sitting at their desk
right now and saying, "Yeah."
- I know, it's like
foreplay with GaryVee.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Then we gotta like
oh sorry I gotta go
do something else.
Do me a favor though--
- It's high school
all over again.
- We're running a
little late but I want
you to do something,
I think it's very important.
Danielle's husband
Sheldon was saying
you gotta tell the jersey story
about giving the jersey to.
- This is actually a very
long story and we don't have
a lot of time,
here's the punchline guys
if you're running a
business actually for the
pretzel gal and
everybody else, Anne Marie,
and everybody else who's
listening who has a business.
Twitter, Twitter.com/search.
- Tell your story,
take your time on it.
- Oh okay.
- I wanna hear the story.
- I wrote a book
several years ago called
"The Thank You Economy."
I've been on this kick
for a long time that
positivity rules, that that's
really where the action is,
and I wanted to
send somebody a gift
as a thank you for buying
wine from WineLibrary.com.
So, somebody places an order
and we find their name
and we find their
Twitter account.
When we look at
their Twitter account,
and this is what
everybody can do
you can go look
up people's names,
find their Twitter account
and then look at it.
And then we looked
at their tweets.
We saw this guy loved
the Chicago Bears.
And he kept talking about
the Bears quarterback
Jay Cutler.
Just kept talking about
it talking about it.
So the guy placed a $100 order
that we made $13 profit on.
But I told my team
to send him a $400
signed Jay Cutler jersey
from eBay, send it
to him and say
thank you for being a
WineLibrary customer.
Right, so the punchline was,
he was gonna write back and
you know, tell us that
he'll buy all his wine
from us for the
rest of his life,
that was my plan.
Here's what happens next.
For three weeks,
we don't hear a thing.
So I call my team I'm like,
"Have we heard anything?"
They go, "No."
I'm like son of a gun,
we sent this guy
a god damn jersey
where the hell is he?
- Yeah.
- You know super upset,
da da da da da.
All of a sudden, I give up on it,
I'm boarding a plane,
I get a call from WineLibrary
and they go,
you've gotta see this.
And I'm like, "What happened?"
I'm like, "The guy?"
They're like, "No,"
I'm like, "Damn."
He goes better.
They read an order that came in
for thousands of
dollars of red burgundy.
And, in the note section it says,
"Hey, WineLibrary.
This is my first order,
"just found out about you.
"First of all, you have
unbelievable prices
"on red burgundy, second of
all, I live in Texas it's hot
"please ship this order
after the summer.
"PS, I found out about
you because you sent
"my friend Steve
"a Bears jersey
"and that's how I became
aware of your business.
"PSS, I'm a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan."
(laughing)
The punchline is
this of that story,
WineLibrary, myself, if
you go look at my account,
we give away stuff all the time,
surprise and delight, find
out what people care about.
A lot of times
they don't write back,
I'm not telling you the story about
when I bought the guy
a PS3 and five games
that I never heard
a peep from him, right?
But when you do the right thing,
the right things happen.
Everybody wants to do something
and expect something in return.
I'm not interested in
coming here and promoting stuff.
I don't need to do that,
I needed to come here
and try to give advice
that 100 people, 1,000 people
that are listening right
now got value out of.
And then that's gonna work
itself out for me one day.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing,
and you can do that in business
and you can do that in life.
- God bless your parents for
instilling that into
you, because obviously--
- No question, I give them,
the circumstances of
being an immigrant
and my parents are
the reason I'm here.
- [Danielle] This is exactly
what my husband does
and it's because of
you like Thanksgiving
he gives all his clients
pies for Thanksgiving
they get to pick a pie
and he has this
great pie giveaway.
But he does these things.
- And do you know what happens?
- [Danielle] Yeah.
- Friends go to friends' homes.
- [Danielle] That's it.
- They're like, you'll
never believe who gave me
this great rhubarb pie.
- [Danielle] Yeah.
- Excellent, GaryVee,
gotta follow him today.
(cheering)
GaryV-E-E.
- GaryV-E-E.
- Follow him.